p-f-t-o-t tuesday edition all by myself
we had big cat today he always runs out
of the studio in new york city as soon
as the show's over sims is on assignment
peter king is going to be joining us on
friday a few things i'd like to get to
that we weren't able to address today we
talked a lot about the monday night game
we talked a lot about the trade deadline
plenty of other topics though still
hovering over the nfl and one the
availability this weekend or next
weekend or the weekend after that of
chiefs quarterback patrick mahomes he
did not play on sunday night when the
chiefs lost the packers chiefs are now
five and three on the year and owen won
without patrick mahomes mahomes had told
michelle tafoya of nbc before the game
that it was a playoff game he would have
played andy reid the coach of the chiefs
chimed in on this and he says that
basically it's going to come down to
what the doctors say
he reid said that mahomes during the
denver game was trying to get back in
after he had the dislocated kneecap so
mahomes wants a play and the chiefs like
that about him but ultimately it's what
the doctors think now here's the thing
to keep in mind at the risk of being
ultracynical but we know how this works
the doctors are paid by the team they
are hired by the team
and if the doctors want to continue to
be hired by the team and work for the
team and it is a very lucrative
assignment in the market where the
doctors are because
if you are providing medical care to the
local nfl team the average person is
going to assume that that must be a good
doctor so you use that to leverage a
bigger practice you make more money and
that's what capitalism is all about
so a key to that is retaining the
relationship with the local nfl team and
one key to retaining the relationship is
sometimes you got to tell them what they
want to hear
so it's not
it's not
laboratory settings it's not determined
in a vacuum
and sometimes the
the doctors and i'm not saying this is
what's going on here we just have to
recognize the bias sometimes the doctors
are listening for those clues
regarding what they think
the patient or the person footing the
bill wants to hear and in a case like
this when the patient wants to play
you know you you almost have to be
careful you don't push back too hard if
you're the doctors because the team may
ultimately say well
if the guy can play then just let him
play we're willing to take some risk if
he's willing to take some risk but
that's ultimately the decision the
chiefs have to make if they do want to
nudge the doctors or not nudge the
doctors if they just want to be ultra
safe maybe what they do in a case like
this is they nudge the doctors towards
saying he can't play so then patrick
mahomes won't get mad at the team won't
get mad at the coach for not letting him
play so you know the pressure can go
both ways
and in the old days the pressure was
always along the lines of pushing the
player
and the team to get the guy on the field
because that's what the coach wanted
now in a case like this who knows maybe
the chiefs are trying to tap the brakes
a little bit
on getting mahomes back on the field
because they understand the risk that
they would be taking by putting their
most important player on the field
prematurely and potentially getting him
injured
one way to protect the most important
player on the field is to have great
blocking and in new england dantes
garnekia the well-respected offensive
line coach is willing to come out and
say that the offensive line isn't good
enough look the offense has struggled
this year and we have focused on the
revolving door at receiver
but skarneke recently said via the
boston herald people have a right to
criticize we are not doing things very
well we're not running the ball very
effectively and it always starts up
front if that's where the blame is going
to go put a target on my chest first
that's how i feel about it i'm
responsible for those guys let's start
there and you know
when you consider
that big cat and i spent
a large chunk of two hours this morning
talking about how matt nagy is handling
difficulty and adversity in chicago how
freddie kitchens is handling how brian
flores
dealt with the ill-advised decision to
call a blitz on
third and 20 with 17 seconds left in the
first half that set up the first
touchdown of the night for the steelers
it's kind of refreshing to have a coach
who
says bluntly and candidly what's going
on and i'll take the blame put it on me
now it helps when you have a fistful of
super bowl rings and when you've reached
an age where you can walk away from the
sport today and it really wouldn't
change your life
but there's something to be learned in
what skarneke has said from some of
these coaches who are early in their
careers and they're not quite sure how
to conduct themselves take it head on
you got to write to criticize look we
have to put a better product on the
field and that's what we're trying to do
and we're not trying to lose we're
trying to win and sometimes in our
effort to win we're going to make some
bad decisions we're going to leave some
things to be desired but rest assured
that we're doing everything we can to
win as many games as possible and look
ultimately kind of hard to criticize the
patriots for anything
there ain't no and they're on their way
by all appearances to another super bowl
berth
and for tom brady it's super bowl number
seven that he could be winning if the
patriots make it again
to the championship game and everyone
thinks that they will at this point at a
minimum to the afc championship game
they've been there every season since
2011. and there's been some talk over
the past week a lot of it was sparked by
adam schefter last monday night on espn
and i don't know if they were just
trying to fill up the time whether or
not schefter was throwing a bone to tom
brady's agent don yee to create some
advanced buzz to maybe get other teams
to offer tom brady
a little bit pre-emptively uh and
prematurely
numbers that could drive the the price
that the patriots have to pay up to keep
tom brady around for 2020 but either way
the word is out there that maybe tom
brady leaves the patriots after this
year maybe he retires after this year
maybe he wins number seven and walks off
into the sunset that's something that
sims believes brady in his weekly visit
to westwood one's monday night football
coverage with jim gray he made it clear
he still intends to play until he's 45.
that's three more seasons beyond this
one
so
despite any buzz despite any rumors
despite anything else brady's got three
years left in him that's what he's been
saying consistently and if you're tom
brady do you really want to start fresh
somewhere else that was the point i made
last week where else do you go that you
have everything set up to be successful
as successful as you've been because
he's going to want to win a super bowl
or at least compete for a super bowl and
if the patrons give him the best chance
that's where he's going to want to be
and he seems to be getting irritated by
all this talk
and uh look at a certain point it does
get old it's like how many different
ways do i have to say it now we'll just
see whether or not he does play for
three more years i always thought he
pegged his retirement at 45
so he would never have a farewell year
and we'd never know which year is his
last year because i think there's a
concern maybe he'd be too emotional in
that farewell year and he doesn't want
it to be all about him it's about the
team because because let's face it if he
does play until his 45 he will have a
farewell year we'll know which year is
his last year unless going into his
farewell year he says i'm not closing
the door on playing next year just to
throw everyone off the scent
so we don't treat his last year as his
last year bottom line to those who think
this is his last year either in football
at all or in new england
i have a feeling it's not and i have a
feeling he'll be back in 2020 with the
new england patriots
and if and when tom brady is back with
new england patriots in 2020 will he
have odell beckham jr as one of his
receivers the two met after the game in
foxborough on sunday apparently odell
beckham jr had a custom-made pair a pair
of cleats goat cleats for tom brady with
goat hair right
uh
so there's a relationship there between
those guys that has existed for a few
years odo beckham jr talked about it
last week they've talked about playing
together
and i think otto beckham jr hoped when
he came to cleveland that the browns
were on track to be coming something
like the patriots
and seven games in it's not looking that
way and the balance of the season i
think is going to go a long way toward
allowing otto beckham jr to determine
whether or not he wants to stay with the
browns after this season and you know
what from the browns perspective
they may be thinking already that this
guy isn't what we thought he was going
to be and maybe it is a little
disruptive for him to be clamoring for
the football and maybe that's affecting
the growth and development of
quarterback baker mayfield because he's
got to factor in that stress that demand
that expectation that odell beckham's
going to get the ball so
look i don't know what's going to happen
and
i guess there's a chance he would get
traded before 4 p.m eastern on tuesday
but i think the next nine games are
going to go a long way toward
determining whether or not odell beckham
jr stay in cleveland lasts more than one
season and i think there's a bigger
chance than we realize based upon the
way things have gone so far that after
one year it could be that the browns
just try to flip him to someone else and
admit mistake admit that it was a bad
idea and move on it becomes easier to do
that if the player begins to clamor to
get out of cleveland and ideally get to
the place where it feels like he's
wanted to go for years and that is new
england and play with tom brady and the
new england patriots before brady turns
45 and ultimately walks away from
football i'm gonna walk away from pftot
because i got nothing else to talk about
we've covered everything we needed to so
far this morning there will be a pft pm
podcast coming up later in the day mds
will join me for the week eight awards
we'll answer some of your questions plus
what we're going to be doing because
we're going to tape it at 3 p.m eastern
in that last hour of the trade window
we'll be reacting in real time to any
trades that do happen between three
o'clock and four o'clock eastern and if
any trades happen before then we'll give
you our thoughts on the deals that are
done between now and the time that pft
pm starts pftot is done we'll see you
later on today for pftpm and check us
out all day long for updates on all
trade rumors and actual deals that are
done or aren't done at
profootballtalk.com
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports